vingt ans vingt ans pour passer d'une
jours au fauteuil de publicitaire mais
veulent tant qu'ils ne sont en fait que
la suite de ce tour du monde c'est le
garçon jean claude bodeau et jacques
séguéla ont fait le tour du monde vous
me direz que ce n'est pas très original
mais ce qui m'a frappé chez eux c'est
qu'ils ont conservé pendant ces quatre
cents jours et ses cent mille kilomètres
un humour et une bonne humeur absolument
une haltère inaltérable et ceci au
travers de circonstance inconfortable
épuisante et même quelquefois dangereuse
l'étions parti pour vivre une grande
aventure l aventure nous l'avons pas
trouvé car il ya longtemps que la
publicité tapageuse des agences de
tourisme et surtout les cars de
touristes belges les avions de touristes
américains l'ont tué et l'ont rapidement
ravagé sur la terre elle n'existe plus
dans le fond un tour du monde c'est un
peu faire le taux de soi même jacques
séguéla lui est un optimiste invétéré il
est revenu en voyant le monde
traditionnellement sous le jour de cette
merveille
ma première merveille c'est le sahara
ont traversé huit désert mensah wright
un désert qui n'est pas comme les autres
c'est un désert ou où le soleil fait la
peinture et je crois qu'en se retirant
de cet immense plage la mer il ya
plusieurs siècles abandonné là un
corsaire nettoierait en bas c'est une
dizaine de jours avec eux sur la tnt